Tony yeah very interesting hearing
doctor it gets mentioned that there may
be a federal need for a law requiring
people to stay home it's a reminder that
these projections while scary are not
destiny we still have the potential to
change them though for now the reports
particularly here in New York are
startling more than 76,000 confirmed
cases some 300 people dead just
yesterday bringing the total here in New
York City to 1700 New York state rather
Milegi is at a naval navy hospital ship
the Comfort docked on the west side of
Manhattan molla good morning yesterday
it was tense in Central Park now it's a
navy ship on the Hudson River
what's that ship going to be used for
well good morning Tony the comfort will
be used for non coronavirus patients
this floating hospital is fully equipped
with a medical laboratory a dozen
operating rooms and a pharmacy among
other things the state of New York
according to Governor Andrew Cuomo has
significantly increased its number of
beds up more than 20 to 75,000 but given
the rate that this virus is spreading he
says we will very likely need twice that
many a grim sight that's being repeated
outside several hospitals in the New
York metro area workers in Brooklyn are
seeing putting a corpse in a
refrigerated truck hospitals across the
city say their ICU are nearly full it's
just surreal actually knowing that I'm
in a disaster zone in New York City
Governor Andrew Cuomo says the state's
peak number of cases could still be
three weeks away we're all in search of
the apex and the other side of the
mountain but we are still headed up
headed up the mountain
among the state's new cases the
governor's brother CNN anchor Chris
Cuomo scarer yes as you might imagine
it's not surprising to me that more of
us are testing positive than ever before
nearly 400 Boston health care workers
have tested positive including more than
a hundred at Brigham and Women's
Hospital by being health care workers
we're not actually able to do what's
being recommended to the rest of the
country which is stay at home more than
400 nursing homes across the country
have infected residents too
have died at this facility in Nashville
Tennessee including Clara summers who
just celebrated her 89th birthday I
would give anything if I could see my
phone it's a grainy one more time and a
growing coronavirus crisis at sea the
USS Theodore Roosevelt is in Guam
carrying some 5,000 crew members nearly
a hundred infected with kovat 19 in a
memo to Navy leaders the captain said
removing all but 10% of the crew is a
necessary risk to stop the virus from
spreading you have very limited room
where you sleep
it's like bunks right on top of each
other Monica box's daughter Cheyenne is
on board
I'm not asking oh you know the Navy oh
please send my daughter home no she's in
the Navy she's a US sailor she can
handle it but at the same point you know
take care of your people jails and
prisons throughout the country have also
struggled to keep their inmates safe
according to the US Department of
Corrections nationally inmates will be
contained to their cells for the next
two weeks in order to try to stop the
spreading of the virus Gail
all right mola thank you